will smith
has apologized for the slap heard round
the world he actually started to
apologize after he won the best actor
award i didn't even know that he won the
best actor award because no one actually
watched the oscars the other night they
just saw that clip of will smith getting
up and smacking chris rock in the face
for telling a joke about his wife
but i guess he won the best oscar and
then during his acceptance speech will
smith alluded a little bit to kind of
almost start to apologize
i know
to do what we do
you got to be able to take
abuse you got to be able to have people
talk crazy about you
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you
and you got to smile and you got to
pretend like that's okay
but richard williams
and what i loved thank you dee
denzel said to me a few minutes ago he
said at your highest moment be careful
that's when the devil comes for you
[Applause]
really good advice
as is usually the case from denzel
washington denzel washington is an
extremely
uh smart guy
there was actually clip of denzel
washington he is i forget when this was
this was a couple of years ago denzel
was asked about some news story about
him that was it's i forget it was
something about his politics he's always
had a reputation as being a little more
conservative than the rest of hollywood
and he just completely scorched the
left-wing media there's been a lot of
buzz about this fake news you were the
subject of a fake news story oh yeah
what they say i was running for
president no no i voted
no what did they say
i switched uh yeah yeah yeah yeah what
do you make of all of fake
effect if you don't read the newspaper
you're uninformed if you do read it
you're misinformed
if you don't read the newspaper you're
writing for it if you do read it you're
misinformed uh this is an old quote
though denzel's
in recent years is the one who's made it
quite popular and uh it's wrongly
attributed to mark twain which is funny
because people who read that it's it's a
mark twain quote in the newspaper are
misinformed but he's totally right if
you don't read the paper you're
uninformed if you do read it you're
misinformed he gives will smith this
good advice at your highest moment
that's when the devil comes for you
that's totally true the devil is just
waiting the devil the devil's a real
person okay antonin scalia
made this point in an interview with new
york magazine some years ago about 10
years ago now
in which
this this silly new york new york
magazine reporter said do you bel you
believe in the devil
you believe in heaven and hell he said i
do i even believe in the devil
do you realize how out of touch you are
with most of america
do you realize how out of touch you are
with most people throughout history
most of whom have believed in the devil
as uh what is it but baudelaire says the
greatest
trick the devil plays is to convince
people that he doesn't exist
so will smith gets that he starts to
kind of almost apologize now he's issued
a full-on apology
to chris rock he says i'm sorry i i
shouldn't have done it it was wrong i
posted it on instagram now it's even
more embarrassing for will smith because
a clip has just come out of will smith
on the arsenio hall show some years ago
in which he himself makes a joke about a
guy who is bald because he's got
alopecia
he has a rule the bass player he got a
rule he got to wax his head every
morning
he follows the rules man he follows the
rules oh these are jokes come on
see you got too into the characters and
got hurt
you gotta love twitter you gotta love
the internet there is a clip there is a
tweet there is a post for everything in
this clip from some years ago
will smith makes
almost the exact same joke
about this musician that
chris rock made about will smith's wife
and then has almost the exact same
reaction as chris rock chris rock reacts
after will smith smacks him chris rock
says it's just a joke it was a gi joke
it wasn't and then in in this clip on
our senior hall will smith says it's
just a joke it's just a joke come on man
i'm a comedian i'm just an entertainer
here
but of course it wasn't about the joke
it wasn't about chris rock i think
that's why chris rock was so shocked and
frankly why will smith was probably
shocked with himself
i i think that the smackered around the
world
probably had a little bit more to do
with the fact that will smith's wife has
brutally cuckled at him and humiliated
him in public for years at this point
and he feels emasculated and humiliated
by that than it does about chris rock
making a relatively mild joke something
and he's just letting out that anger and
that shame that he feels on chris rock
and why does he feel it the argument
that jada smith and i guess will smith
were making when they aired their dirty
laundry on tv was look this isn't a big
deal oh we have all these cultural
hang-ups over infidelity but come on
that's just that's just old-fashioned
that's just irrational it's fine
we can
you know jada smith she has a kind of
encounter
with this guy that she was sleeping with
she has a kind of it's a it's a minor
indiscretion it's well but it's fine
and we can let's talk about this openly
there's no shame in that but of course
there is of course there is and of
course will smith is humiliated and i
feel terrible for the guy
i feel genuinely terrible for will smith
because even when chris rock makes the
joke will smith started laughing and
then he looked over at jada smith and
jada didn't like it and i i tell you i
don't like to get into psychobabble much
i could read his mind
you could see the wheels turning in will
smith's head he thought oh i've already
been so emasculated i've already been so
humiliated i've already literally been
cuckolded
before the entire public i'm a very
famous guy huge movie star i've been
as humiliated as you possibly can be to
be a cuckold is one of the most
humiliating things that there is in the
italian culture
we'll tell you someone of italian
extraction that's it's it's one of the
worst things you can call somebody you
call them a coronuto the sign of the
cuckold actually the the rock and roll
symbol you know where you put your hands
in the air that's an italian symbol for
the evil eye and it's the sign of the
cuckold
you're saying i'm gonna but you know i'm
you don't want to be a cuckold you want
you want your enemies to be cuckled i
mean it's so humiliating and he's he's
looking he says god can't do it i can't
let this happen until he goes up and
smacks him then he feels bad about it
your highest moment the devil's going to
come and get you
this this will smith
incident people are still talking about
it because it kind of confuses political
lines
you've got some people who are and
to some degree myself included who are
sympathetic with will smith who like the
idea that it's kind of chivalrous to get
up there and defend your woman's honor
how dare you sir i challenge you to a
duel i demand satisfaction
i i am sympathetic to that i don't think
people should be allowed to say whatever
they want i mean there's not even a
first amendment protection for fighting
words there's always been a carve out
for fighting words among other things i
talk about this in my book speechless
the founding fathers wouldn't have
rolled over for a joke about a man's
wife they would have smacked him across
the face they probably would have
challenged him to a duel but on the
other hand we're talking about a
comedian here chris rock the guy is paid
to go and tell jokes about celebrities
in the room and not only is will smith a
celebrity but jada smith has made
herself a celebrity she's not exactly a
homemaker she's not donna reed okay
she's not staying at home as a
traditional
stay-at-home wife no she's a public
figure and so she's open to that kind of
public criticism for better and for
worse the problem here
with will smith's reaction
is that it wasn't this principled
totally in controlled dignified response
hello sir i demand satisfaction he lost
his school he was not at all in
self-control and that was even more
humiliating for him
i'm glad you like that clip now what i
need you to do is ring the bell
subscribe get all the notifications also
if you can head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify wherever you get
your podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]